the more we know about biology the more
that we understand that you can't really
study biology in isolation to get a firm
understanding of how biological systems
evolve so EB major is highly
interdisciplinary in terms of the
students can take courses and hear
lectures and experience fieldwork where
we cover things from mathematical
understandings of biological systems
obtaining gene sequences and genomic
data including traditional techniques
and next-generation sequencing they can
learn about synthetic biology ways that
researchers are literally being able to
create life in the laboratory you have
to understand the underlying chemistry
physics there might be engineering
principles there are many different
facets taken from other sciences that
merge very well with biology modern
biology for us to understand the natural
world and how organisms will evolve
within it I would say the EE B major
should very much appeal to students who
are excited about research so students
can take what they have learned in the
classroom and construct research
projects to go out to their favorite
habitats and this could range from
desert habitats to the poles to the
oceans basically anywhere that students
can use their imagination and examine
the organisms that thrive in those
habitats and get hands-on experience
being in the field this is something
that we pride ourselves on and ideally
their research could even be published
in a major journal so right now we're
inside the hidden part of the Yale
Peabody Museum of Natural History and
this is where Yale houses its vertebrate
collections within the museum so this
ranges from fish specimens birds
reptiles mammals all sorts of creatures
that have been gathered from around the
world for a good reason for the purpose
of conducting research and better
understanding the ecology and evolution
living world so our major prepares
students for a variety of things that
they might want to do in the future we
have students that are pre-med pre-vet
pre-dental so a lot of the things that
you might associate with a biology
degree but also we recognize that
students may be attracted and prepared
to go into industry so they could work
in terms of finding new biofuels and
doing work and bioremediation but there
are all sorts of vital skills that we
provide in terms of understanding
biology both of the organisms that
surround us as well as ourselves that
will help prepare students no matter
what it is that they wants to do in the
future